surveillance video shows Ivory run after
the manager and into his office when she
approaches he punches her in the face
while the security video doesn't when it
gets to a point where a young man
reached out and hit an older black woman
you don't hit somebody you don't hit
people but I can also understand why he
did he was defending himself you chased
him into a closed office where he had no
point of exit
right that was the point I was forcing
him to have a conversation
he decided to take a stand
this is my Rosa Parks moment dude
you don't play with me this mindset in
America in the western world is a
sickness
it is deviant and we do not want it body
camera video captures Target manager
Ashley Meyer describing to police what
happened so I I came around and I was
like hey what can I do for you okay
usually it's like like the price is
wrong or whatever
she starts going on this this year
about how like I've had a privileged
life and she's been disadvantaged and
then said that she was asking Target to
make reparations for her
hey hey yeah you didn't know where this
was gonna go right I had I haven't I
still I had no idea I still have no clue
where this is going she had a lot of
groceries I just want to I just split
display we don't know [__] we don't know
[__] we do know a lot I want to know
more
reparations at Target I want to know
okay I want to hear from her too tonight
if like if you need a donation like you
can ask Mario
can do for you like right now okay and
then she was like she was like you need
to put me in touch with someone tonight
and I was like I can't there isn't
yeah and then she got really close to me
so I put my hands up and backed up and
she like followed me she was like like
breathing into my eyeballs
that's hot
I'm sorry sorry I didn't expect
breathing into my eyeballs but at the
same time you got glasses so she was
really just fogging them [__] up
you guys know that one foreign
she was breathing into my eyeballs it's
very intense you imagine
get the [__] out of there
yeah you did this is what it looks like
when someone's breathing into your eye
look into my mouth
like what the [__] is this I told you
right you felt a little uneasy I told
you that [__] kind of hot
laughs
all right let me see she's screaming at
you or yeah yeah so she got really close
to me I put my hands up I touched her
shoulders because she was like coming
into my space okay
um and then she like because I touched
her she like anything
after that and just started screaming
really loudly and like back against the
soda machine okay and then that's when
like
yeah he called she called our security
person security video shows the incident
unfolded the manager I guess it is in
the back of your head I'm sorry I lost
track of what this video was about for a
second I thought it was gonna make out
so like I caught a chip
[Music]
right now
bold as Ivory approaches
[Laughter]
no she really went like that but it
looked like that yeah uh welcome to
Target you know what I mean like
sorry
[__] off all right let's keep watching
this fanfic and gets in her face after
that a loss prevention manager
approaches so what happened
she okay
I came up I tried to verbally
de-escalate she told me that she wanted
to wreck it out and I told her we
couldn't do that okay and then she said
excuse me and I was like man like I need
your back up or leave like well we can't
do that for you so she started talking
at me I came all the way back into my
office into an enclosed space and I hit
her in the face surveillance video shows
Ivory run after the manager and into his
office when she approaches he punches
her in the face while the security video
does not hey
Haymaker hey hey he hit her so hard her
credit cards got rejected look at them
shits on the floor
insufficient funds and they all just
roll down like that look at these cards
did you not see the cars just roll out
they they blurred it out but after she
took a punch you like one of them
[__] Mario characters every time they
hit a trap
Sonic the Hedgehog
2023 just credit cards falling out
because nobody got real money anymore
the manager later described the incident
to police on body camera video I tried
that
literally close her out but at that
point she was like pretty much running
so she barreled her way in and then Kate
kept coming into my office she was not
running but
when you're backing up like that that
person that's going like that is much
more fast than you is so I um I'm gonna
yeah I'm just gonna go understand what
the [__] I mean it might as well be
running okay
you just hit her and that's it hit her
like right in the face like a girl I
tried to close you out of my office and
you just kept on pushing your way in
that's right no sir I didn't push my way
in I can't no I came around the corner
quickly hey would you quit talking hey
no excuse you stop talking when I'm
telling you you stop talking okay
do you know who I am uh we'll figure
that out when I get your ID
he said do you know who I am I think
this girl might have mental issues it's
great when he says like well I'm gonna
try I'm trying to figure it out when I
get your idea but you don't want to give
that [__] to me so we'll figure it out
yeah one of the cards that fell out
gotta be her ID Ivory later tells police
officers the incident stemmed from her
request for reparations on her purchase
so what caused the history today
and we're gonna have a big discussion
here I asked my questions who are you
going to have this big discussion with
Target whatever in Target I need you to
speak
okay
[Music]
foreign
actually no the young lady got in life
and she pushed me too she put her hands
on me as well
I put my hands on no one I came close to
them and they felt threatened
his hers was a push back
yeah just to separate you from right
with Your Inner Space yeah
oh great cool why did you feel friend
because you're coming at her cause
you're breathing on her eyeballs you're
coming at her and she's smaller than you
you like she arrived at your titties my
girl
yo get this girl out of here man it
depends on I don't know what this
discussion is about what were you asking
her to do reach out to her manager so we
can have a larger discussion about how
money works and how provision works and
how it's been working I imagine
run it we're good run it we're good
we're gonna have a conversation at
Target about how money Works my girl
a little bit more
you can elaborate a little bit during
the further details
Ivory calls the incident her quote Rosa
Parks moment
with the support of my community
why are you alone then
hey any of the black people were helping
around who are part of this community
can y'all Post in the comments she
having a Rosa Parks moment she said
y'all with her
anybody
to find out
I decided to take a stand this is my
Rosa Parks moment dude
don't play with me body camera video
captures Ivory speaking with officers
for more than 30 minutes stressing the
statement she was trying to make we're
having a conversation about how to
reconcile the fact that some people
benefited from the system with who I
could talk to what was your purpose of
that kind that further conversation what
were you going to ask that person for to
do
to break the lies around money
what's that mean
we all know money has not been treating
everybody equally okay
money is not the only way for things to
happen because I know the heart of this
place
okay it's the right place for me to have
this conversation I'm sorry it's a good
company exactly and I was trying to have
a hard conversation in a safe place I
did it the right way and then when I was
I went through the right steps the
reason the problem with my money doesn't
work right is because it blocks people
and checkpoints and I'm tired of locking
good people out you don't get paid but
you deserve outside no no that is not
going to either you walk out on your own
or hang ups hello will be arrested for
this cause
where are you holding your lines at come
on you are under arrest yes you're under
arrest for menacing and disorderly
conduct okay now here's what we would
like to do we would rather you walk
outside and not make a big deal if
you're going to make money
yes we will let's go some of them
don't get resisting to
all right let's do it what's nice we're
gonna go into it let's do it oh my God
there's no way I ain't listening to this
[__] well listen she got arrested
she got put in handcuffs good because
she deserves it
foreign
thoughts
um to me it's just something that
happened uh
you come up in the spot and you talk to
the employees about something that they
have like
yeah you come up in the spot and you
talk to the employees talking about some
[__] that they don't even know what the
[__] is going on
and then you push nobody but you come at
them
and the guy is backing up like he is
backing up
you can't hit a woman I can't well she
tried to Corner me get up in my face he
did what he could to not [__]
escalate she kept coming forward he had
nowhere else to back at this point
the thing is he doesn't he doesn't even
understand what your point is nope so he
doesn't even okay this doesn't make any
sense so at this point I'm in my office
I don't know what's next step what's
gonna happen or nothing there's a lot of
things that goes on your head when
things like that happen when someone
comes to you like someone comes to me
like and I've been walking the street
and eggs someone's like hey and I'm like
I'm trying to figure out what is this
about yeah so I'm thinking my mind is
going a hundred miles an hour trying to
figure out first do I know the person no
I don't know the person what is the
person talking about okay that person
just want to say hi well that hey was
abrasive good it's fine hey but then
after you keep on going rambling about
[__] I don't know what's next hey man we
even gotta explain this so the [__] is
crazy she definitely got mental issues I
don't got no sympathy for her and she's
a lost cause as far as something she
going to jail good that's all I've got
anything else nope all right listen